[Music]
in the trailer of Godzilla and Kong the
new Empire we saw quite a few different
Titans and monsters of course we also
got a chance to see Kong Again Godzilla
again the scar King more clearly a tribe
or an army of tens to hundreds of Kongs
and one particular ape that has caught
the attention of many this is the mini
Kong which was seen as an ape dollar
with red fur yet it was gigantic in size
but this isn't the first time we have
seen a young ape titan the first was of
course Kong as a young ad doson in Skull
Island back in the 1970s so here in this
video we will compare these two the mini
Kong and the adolesent Kong their sizes
each different features as well as their
habitat they grew in to get to the
bottom of it all let's get to it let's
let's take a look firstly at their
designs and features here in the
monsterverse Kong diverges away from the
2005 version by being ught and more
human-like in posture he has way longer
arms as compared to his legs which gives
him a distinct Outlook of a silhouette
Kong has a muscular physique with
defined abs and large biceps Kong's fur
is a light brown color and covers the
majority of his body except for his face
his chest his belly uh hands and feet
his skin is dark gray in color and he
has large scars running across his chest
and his face resembles that of a mature
gorilla the mini Kong however while also
bearing a similar body posture has even
longer arms as compared to the 2017 Kong
he has orange red fur that covers his
body except for the face hands and feet
and his skin color is dark gray the
difference here is that the fur also
covers the chest and the belly unlike
Kong which has no fur in that part of
the body the face of Minong seems to be
more monkey likee or rather more baby
likee with the eyes especially being
huge relative to the face which shows
his young
age now let's discuss their sizes and
compare them to one another the adults
and Kong that was seen in 2017 well the
movie Skull Island was stated to be 104
ft or almost 32 m in height he was three
times taller than the tallest extinct
dinosaur the Brachiosaurus or dread naus
that puts him as as a 10-story building
the mini as seen in gxc the new empire
trailer is also gigantic even though he
doesn't seem like it in the trailer in
one of the scenes in the trailer we see
him and Kong along with many other Kongs
in the hollow Earth in that volcanic
region before being confronted by the
scar King right here we get to witness
him being nearby Kong who as an adult is
roughly 337 ft or 103 M tall Now by mq
Magic we can crop out the mini Kong and
Pace him right beside the main Kong to
get a size estimation Kong here looks to
be 2 and 1 half times taller therefore
that makes the Mini Kong 40% the height
of Kong which puts him at roughly 130 to
140 ft or 40 to 42 M tall therefore he
is taller than the Adolescent Kong of
2017 out sizing him by 9 M or 30 ft okay
so with these differences stated out
let's discuss both of these Kongs age
and their growth rate so we know that
Kong was the last surviving member of
his species in Skull Island he was born
sometime in the late 1800s or the early
1900s because when he was first
encountered in 1945 by gpe iari and H
Marlo he was already bigger than any
animal they had ever seen and yeah he
was stated to be a young ad doson by the
time of the events of Skull Island which
is chronologically in the
1970s 1973 he then got a growth boost
and grew to be the the Titan he is now
50 years later this mini Kong however
doesn't seem to look like an adson or a
young adult he appears to be a little
kid more than a toddler but less than a
prein by our human standards somewhere
in the 8 to 10 year old range as by us
but these are Titans this ape could be
could very well be decades old and still
look like a baby now what could be the
reason as to why this pre-adolescent
mini Kong is taller than a young
adolescent Kong of Skull Island as far
as I can think of there are three
probable factors that would influence
this difference in size between the two
firstly individual meaning that just
like us humans there are some which grow
faster than others while there are some
which are taller or shorter than others
some who hit puberty at a younger age
While others who have a late onset of
puberty So minic Kong could just be an
oversized individual while Kong on the
other hand could be one of the runs of
the litter come on we all know a tall
and a short kid in school right right
that could very well be one of the
factors the second reason is that he is
of a different species or a subspecies
of Kong he might be an offspring of the
scar king or a hybrid one that came out
of a union between the red villain and a
female Kong from the bunge he might
possess what biologists say a hybrid
Vigor meaning an enhanced trait that
shows up in The Offspring of two
different races of subspecies like a
lier which is way bigger than both its
parents a male lion and a female tiger
that could also be it while the third
Factor could be the hollow Earth
radiation which is theorized to be the
reason as to why these super species
only develop in this part of the planet
and not on the surface while Kong who
already has Titan DNA would grow only as
much as he is genetically programmed to
grow this mini Kong however might get a
boost from the hollow Earth radiation
and that is the third and final Factor
so it could be one of these or a
combination of two or even all all three
factors together now the final question
how big will this mini Kong grow so even
as a young ape he is around 140 ft in
height imagine when he hits puberty and
go through the Adolescent changes and
becomes an adult woo if he follows the
growth rate of Kong he might as well
grow to be 150 M or 500 ft in height or
even bigger but that would be just over
the top but if this happens he would be
bigger than most titans bigger than
Godzilla and almost as tall as Monster
Zero at its prime so yeah this is one
thing that we should think of quite
often maybe before sleep so if you like
this video then check this other one as
well and if you want to see other
monster content then check out our
Channel we might have things especially
from the monster us that you haven't
seen before like subscribe and we'll see
you in the next video take care
fam
[Music]